Marvel Studios has done it again... stoked
the ire of some fans on the internet, that
is.
While reactions to the first trailer for the
upcoming Black Widow were largely positive,
a certain subset of fans took issue with what
they perceived as the fat-shaming of the Red
Guardian, portrayed by Stranger Things' David
Harbour.
The Guardian, real name Alexei Shostkov, appears
at a couple of different moments in the trailer.
Russia's answer to Captain America is portrayed
as being perhaps a decade or two past his
prime, and suffice to say that Harbour — never
the trimmest of actors — didn't exactly
get jacked for the role.
This is obviously by design, as we first see
Shostakov flexing his admittedly considerable
muscles in a mirror, then attempting to squeeze
into his old suit. He does, then proudly announces
to his "family" — Scarlett Johansson's Natasha
Romanoff , Florence Pugh's Yelena Belova,
and Rachel Weisz's Melina Vostokoff — that
it still fits.
"Yeah! Still fits."
That's when Vostokoff says:
"You got fat."
However, in the spot's very next scene, we
see that the Guardian's added heft doesn't
seem to be slowing him down much, as he single-handedly
takes on the villainous Taskmaster.
The response from some fans online was highly
reminiscent of the "Fat Thor" controversy
after the release of Avengers: Endgame. Many
were incredulous that Marvel appeared not
to have learned anything from said controversy,
including Twitter user @The_GothDaddy, who
wrote:
"The Black Widow trailer looks pretty good
I'd like it more if Marvel learned their lesson
with Thor and maybe considered leaving out
yet... A n o t h e r... Dig at fat people."
User @Artists_Al agreed, writing:
"So I watched the Black Widow trailer. Is
Marvel just gonna do wall to wall fatphobic
jokes in all their movies now or....? Yeah
that's gonna be a no from me."
There were a wealth of similar tweets to be
found in the trailer's immediate wake, and
while everybody is obviously entitled to their
opinion, ours is that — as with the Endgame
controversy — the approach to Harbour's
character is being wildly misinterpreted.
User @MediocreJedi contributed another critical
tweet that touched on our reasoning:
"Imma watch the hell out of #BlackWidow but
did Marvel learn ANYTHING from their Endgame
Thor fat joke backlash? Most women I know
find David Harbour hot. So, another fat joke?
Signed, guy who can barely fit into his 21-year-old
dress uniform but can still kick ass."
While one could certainly make the argument
that Marvel didn't exactly think through the
potential ramifications before committing
to their portrayal of Red Guardian, we submit
that those accusing the studio of fatphobia
would do well to take a look at the broader
context of the spot. Sure, the fact that Shostakov
is old and out of shape, squeezing into his
superhero costume only for his "family" to
poke good-natured fun at him, is played for
a laugh. Does this make the Red Guardian a
buffoon, a punchline, like some in the Twitterverse
are asserting?
Respectfully, we don't agree that it does.
Again, in the very next scene, we see the
Guardian in all his overweight glory engaging
one-on-one with one of the deadliest villains
in the Marvel universe — and everything
about his appearance in this sequence, regardless
of how many extra pounds he may be packing,
screams "utter badass."
Those raking Marvel over the coals on Twitter
obviously took away something different, and
that's unfortunate — but we certainly didn't
see Marvel encouraging audiences to point
and laugh at the hapless fat guy. What we
saw was much more along the lines of, "Hey,
Alexei may be past his prime; he has to struggle
to get into his old suit, and his family ribs
him about it. He may not have the body of
Captain America, but he can damn sure throw
down like him."
To us, this is the exact opposite of fat-shaming,
and we took a similar position in defense
of Fat Thor — AKA "Bro Thor." Yes, it was
a shock to the system to see the God of Thunder
having packed on the pounds, swilling beer
and playing video games, and Chris Hemsworth
leaned into the comedic aspects of his first
onscreen appearance in that state. Yes, Tony
Stark made fun of him; Stark made fun of everybody,
every chance he got.
But Thor's extra pounds, and the profound
depression of which they were a symptom, were
not treated as a joke. In contrast, Odinson's
descent into depression in the wake of his
failure to stop Thanos in Avengers: Infinity
War was treated with a great deal of sensitivity,
and the entire arc was one which we would
never have expected for the character.
With Red Guardian and Bro Thor alike, Marvel
seems to be pretty darn consistent in its
message, which is a timeless one: don't judge
a book by its cover. You might be old, you
might be chubby, you might be depressed; you
can be any or all of these things, and you
can still be a hero. That is a message anyone
should be able to get behind.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon. Subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one.